This is the 99% invisible breakdown of the Constitution. I'm Roman Mars. And I'm Elizabeth Joe. Today we are finishing up our discussion of Article 2, which establishes the executive branch of the federal government. Our special guest for this episode is Dr. Tom Frieden, who served as director of the Center for Disease Control and Prevention under President Obama from 2009 to 2017. We brought him on to talk about the experience of being a highly trained expert in an inherently political institution. that was once considered to be about as apolitical as you can get, but not so much anymore. Dr. Frieden was also the New York City Public Health Commissioner under Mayor Bloomberg from 2002 to 2009,
and he talks about the difference between running a city health agency and a federal health agency. Which one had the most power might surprise you. But first, Elizabeth is going to take us through Article 2, section by section. We covered Article 1 before that was addressing Congress, its powers and limitations. Now let's take a brief tour of Article 2. Okay. All right. So Article 2 can be seen as doing a couple of things, specifying the selection of the
president and the function of the executive branch, listing the specific powers of the president, listing the duties of the president, and what to do with a constitutionally inadequate president. Okay. So there are some, just like with Article 1, some very important aspects of the executive branch that are in Article 2, but some things that are not in Article 2. at all, but nevertheless important. So we'll get to those. But I think the big thing, unlike our discussion about Congress, is that with Article 2, a huge force affecting Article 2 is Trump and the
Supreme Court's treatment of Trump. Trump has had a very significant impact on how we think about the powers of the presidency. So let's start with Section 1. Section 1 contains the vesting clause, which says, the executive power shall be vested in a president of the United States of America. Now, we saw a vesting clause in Article 1 as well, but Article 1 and Article 2 have a notable difference. Article 1 says, all legislative powers herein granted shall be vested in a Congress. Article 2 doesn't refer to just powers here in granted. Now, you could say, well, maybe that was just a lapse on the part of the drafters, but maybe not because that suggests there are some ambiguity as to whether the powers in Article 2 are just examples, or are they the only powers
the president has? Wow. Now, the spoiler, of course, is that every president has said, no, we have more. We have more than what's in Article 2, right? Yeah. And practically speaking, we've treated presidents as having some more power than what's specifically laid out in Article 2, but of course, the contested part is always how much power. So that's the opener.
Section 1 also describes our system of using electors and the Electoral College. Each state appoints electors equal to the number of senators and electors. And Article 2 is a compromise, right, between directly electing the president by popular vote or having the president selected by Congress directly. There is, of course, a popular vote, but when we all vote, we are actually voting for a slate of electors appointed by our state's political parties. And that means the important number is not 50. 1% of everyone voting, but 270 of the 538 electoral votes up for grabs.
Because of Article 2, a presidential candidate can win the popular vote, but lose the electoral college and not become president, like Hillary Clinton did in 2016, and Al Gore did in 2000. This system is so central that, of course, we did have a fake electors plot during the 2020 presidential election, and that was when Republican officials and several battleground states came up with a scheme to submit fake certificates, claiming that Trump actually won in states like Arizona and Georgia. And these were acts designed to overturn the legitimate election of Joe Biden. And dozens.
It just was so many scandals ago that I forgot this fundamental one that is truly mind-blowing just in and of itself. If that was the only scandal a president had, that would be enough to disqualify them in my mind. Right, but it was also both dastardly and completely inept. No one really thought it was going to work. I guess so. So dozens of people have been indicted on these state criminal charges for participating in these fake elector schemes. In fact, the fake elector scheme was part of the criminal conspiracy alleged by special counsel Jack Smith and discussed in the criminal indictment of Trump in 2023. And of course, the Supreme Court put an end to that in 2024 with its decision on.
presidential immunity. And the re-election of Trump ensured that the Justice Department would drop the remainder of the case, which it did. Now, Article 2 then addresses the question of succession. If something happens to the president, let's say the president dies or somehow is unable to be president anymore. And while Article 2 is actually superseded by the 25th Amendment in 1967, after that amendment, there is no question that the vice president becomes the president when the president dies or resigns or does something similar. There was some ambiguity before the 25th Amendment. But now we know for certain that there is vice presidential succession
after the president can no longer be president. Oh, cool. The 25th Amendment also gives power to Congress to establish the line of succession. What if the vice president dies or can't serve in some other way? And so just as a little piece of information, the Presidential Succession Act today would mean, in order.
You ready? Oh, yeah, please. President Vance, President Mike Johnson, President Chuck Grassley, who, by the way, is 92, President Marco Rubio, President Scott Bessent, and President Pete Hegseth. Oh, my God. Yes, you can pick among all of those people. That's just, it's purely theoretical, though, purely theoretical. That's so miserable. Okay.
Oh, my God. Okay. And Article 2 then goes on to talk about the domestic. I know, it's a, it just say the list. I'm just like, okay, it can't get worse and it can't get worse. And it's like, yeah, I think actually Haxeth would be worse. You know, like, oh, my God, okay. But so many things would have to happen for us to have President Pete Haxson
and let us not wish for any of those things happen. Absolutely. Okay, so then class seven of Article 2 contains the domestic emoluments clause. Let's go back to this for a second. The president shall not receive any amolument from the United States or any of them. And this is the plain English of this is the president can't receive any gift from the federal government or any of the state governments. This is similar to the foreign emoluments clause, which can actually be found in Article 1, which says that no person holding any office of profit or trust except any emolument from any king, prince, or foreign state without the consent of Congress. Remember that in Trump's first term, a group of lawsuits were filed alleging that Trump had violated both the foreign and the domestic emoluments clauses.
And the basis of their claims was that Trump's continued stake in his business interests had led to some kind of improper influence. So, for example, if a representative of a foreign government was staying at the Trump International Hotel in Washington, D.C., maybe we could think of that as an improper gift to the president, right? We never, of course, found out whether they were unconstitutional emoluments because after Trump left office in 2021, these lawsuits were declared moot, no longer live, is sure. that a federal court could decide. So we never really got the answer about whether or not these were unconstitutional emoluments. Yeah. And then emoluments after a moment. There's an emolument every hour at this point.
Yeah. Surprisingly, there haven't been any lawsuits that I'm aware of. But again, we don't know the answer. Yeah. Okay. Now, section two of Article 2 specifies the powers of the president. Clause 1 tells us that the president is the commander-in-chief of the military. Right?
So we have talked a bit about the war power and the power. the fact that in our system, the president, who is a civilian, is in charge of the armed forces. And that's a very deliberate choice. So there are some other powers here. But the other thing I want to mention now is that Section 2 of Article 2 includes the pardon power. Article 2 says that the president shall have power to grant reprieves and pardons for offenses against the United States, except in cases of impeachment. So what this means is that the Constitution gives the president, authority to grant pardons. And the only real limits here are that they can only be used for
federal criminal offenses. So you can't use them for state offenses or civil claims of any kind. And it cannot be used in cases of impeachment. And the president's pardon power is so broad that the Supreme Court has said previously that the power of the presidency is not subject to legislative control. And there have been, of course, many controversial pardons in the past. you know, for instance, in 2001, President Clinton pardoned his brother Roger for his conviction on drug offenses, and everyone thought, well, that's just using his influence to help out his family, right? But Trump is a little bit different.
Trump has taken this pardon power much, much further. So, for instance, on December 1st, Trump pardoned former Honduran President Juan Orlando Hernandez. Hernandez, why was he being pardoned? He had been sentenced to 45 years in prison for conspiring to import cocaine, to the United States. Why am I mentioning this? Because this is just months after the administration began to blow up boats in the Caribbean because it claims that these boats are carrying narco-terrorists smuggling drugs into the United States from Venezuela. So a little bit of an inconsistency there. Have they ever spoken to why they did that pardon? Like even their own story of this?
You know, just unfair, witch hunt, too long with sentence, et cetera. And Roger Stone reportedly lobby the president directly on Hernandez's behalf, Stone's a longtime Trump advisor, and apparently it worked. Okay. And on January 20th, as one of Trump's very first acts in a second term, there's a pretty significant use of the pardon power. Trump pardoned nearly all of the 1,600 people charged in connection with the attack on the Capitol on January 6th, 2021. Trump also commuted the sentences of 14 members of the proud boys and the oathkeeper groups. And commutations are also part of the pardon power. These were folks primarily convicted of seditious conspiracy.
As part of his pardon order here, Trump also ordered the Justice Department to dismiss all pending indictments against people who were still facing charges for January 6th. Now, months later, the Justice Department also took the very broad position that criminal cases that were secondary to the January 6 attacks were also covered by the pardon, although some judges, have already rejected these claims. So that's, for instance, they were, after January 6th, let's say investigators were looking
for evidence of your involvement in the attacks on the Capitol, and while they were searching your home, they found illegal firearms or illegal drugs. You know, these folks have said, well, you know, I'm covered by this pardon. And the Justice Department said, well, yeah, sure, because they're somehow related in a very tangential way to investigating your involvement in January 6th, which, of course seems kind of crazy, right? Yeah, for sure. This is a pretty extraordinary use of the pardon power.
I mean, definitely presidents in the past have used a mass pardon power, but this is of a different order altogether. This mass pardon is a political statement by Trump. This was an attempt to shut down a constitutional process on January 6th. And Trump's really saying these acts are not worthy of punishment, not at all. So that seems pretty significant. Is there another example of a mass pardon that was sending a political message? If I'm not mistaken, like, Carter pardoned all the draft daughters. Right, right, right.
Yeah. But, yeah, I mean, for sure, we might say that I'm certain there were people who disagreed with it at the time. But it's not quite the same political statement, isn't it? I mean, I think the same idea of mass political pardons. And, you know, they did in fact violate the law. But here, you know, you might say that the attack on the Capitol was a kind of attack on the very structure of the Democratic. process, right? And Trump's undoing of it, which was well within his power, is a way of saying, this is completely fake. There's nothing that they did wrong. In effect, you know, you could do it all
again. It would be fine. I mean, that's essentially the message of it. Yeah. Yeah. There's no punishment whatsoever. Yeah, but you could say that the, you know, the structure of the armed forces is, you know, relies on the draft and therefore, you know, these people fundamentally undermined that structure and, you know. True. True. That's what, you know, I suppose you could say that. But I think probably the January 6 attack was of a very different magnitude. Totally. Totally different. I'm not saying it's not different. All I'm saying is that you could make a political argument that both of them are undermining the norms of our both political military and governmental system. And it certainly was destabilizing to have people avoid the draft and while that sort of thing. Yeah, true, true. Although I think we still would have had a government that was standing.
Not totally clear to what would happen if an attack had been successful in January 6th. Fair enough. I really would prefer not to think about that. No. And on December 11th, this is another interesting one, Trump pardoned Tina Peters. Peters is a former county clerk in Colorado. She's an election fraud conspiracies. Oh, yeah.
And she was convicted of election interference. Here's the kicker. I'm not sure what to call this. A symbolic pardon, a nonsensical pardon, an outrageous pardon. Because remember, Article 2 gives Trump the authority to pardon someone for an offense against the United States. She was convicted on state charges. It is absolutely a meaningless pardon. He can say whatever he likes. And in fact, I suppose we could say it's not really a pardon at all because it is not permissible for a president to pardon someone on state charges. But these are
the sorts of things that he's doing and everyone says, well, what does that mean? And the answer is it means nothing. If a lawyer was thinking about getting convictions for people who are sympathetic to Trump, usually or used to be that the gold standard for getting a conviction is you bring up federal charges because you have the weight of the federal government to prosecute. And that's really scary when all of a sudden it's like kicked up to the feds. It's a big, big, big deal. Right. But tactically, it makes more sense today to make, you know, some of these things state charges if that's appropriate. Is anyone thinking like that? I don't know if anyone's thinking like that, but that certainly makes sense at the federal level
if you want to avoid federal charges. There's definitely more of a sense that there's a perhaps a pay-to-play system in some aspects of the criminal justice system now, not just only getting a pardon, but maybe you'll have charges that are dropped or charges that are never brought at all. And, of course, that is deeply corrupting
of the criminal justice system. And so, yeah, I assume that the flip side could happen as well. You know, not sure anybody would want to admit to that right now. Structurally, the incentives are certainly there. The incentives are there to use state courts to convict someone. I think so. Right. I think so. Yeah. Although, you know, one example, though, is that if you do that, like if you think about the post-January 6 attempts to prosecute or bring criminal prosecution at the
state level, look what happened, which was harassment, intimidation of the very prosecutors that we saw in Georgia and elsewhere. You know, you can try to bring state charges, but then you have the entire apparatus of the right-wing media and people who the president himself may call you out and threaten you. So there is that. Yeah. So then Article 2 goes next to bring in the Senate. In clause 2, the president can make treaties with the advice and consent of the Senate. So here we now have a partnership with a part of Congress. Now with the advice and consent of the Senate, the president can also appoint ambassadors, Supreme Court justices, and all other officers of the United States. That's why we see televised hearings whenever the president selects new
members of his cabinet. All of the secretaries must be given Senate approval, and same is true, for instance, of federal judges. But there's a more complicated part of this clause, which is called the Appointments Clause. Article 2 refers to the president's ability to appoint officers of the United States, but the Congress may, by law, vest the appointment of such inferior officers as they think proper in the president alone or in the courts of law or in the heads of departments. Now, okay, I got to say pretty dry, very boring part of Article 2, right? Well, it's more confusing than boring. Yes, it's very confusing. Not at all obvious to most people what this means or why it's even important, but it is important. So think of officers as the top people
in the executive branch who don't make up the vast majority of federal employees. Those folks are in the civil service, right? They're not appointed by the president. So the Supreme Court has interpreted this part of Article 2 to mean that there are two kinds of officers of the United States, principal officers and inferior officers. Now, principal officers have to be appointed by the president and confirmed by the Senate. So a member of the president's cabinet has to be appointed by. the president himself and then confirmed by the Senate. Inferior officers can be, but they don't
have to be. They can be appointed by another part of the federal government. So think of the appointments clause as the hiring clause of the Constitution. When can the president hire people himself or when can Congress decide, hey, we want some other part of the government to do the hiring of these top executive officials? Okay. So that's hiring. Pretty important, right? Who gets to run different aspects of the federal government. Sure. Now, here's the other aspect. Hiring implies firing, right?
That's something we think of, well, presidents can do that, right? Well, the problem here is that Article 2 says nothing about when officers can be fired or to use the constitutional language be removed from office. So what we have is a set of practices in the Supreme Court. everyone agrees that the president can certainly fire members of his own cabinet for any reason. The Secretary of Defense, Secretary of State, they can all just be fired because the president just wakes up one day and says, I don't like you. You're fired. That's fine. That's absolutely within the president's power. And our guest for later on in today's episode, Tom Frieden, who was director of the CDC, he held a position that could be fired by the president for any reason, any reason at all. I don't agree with you or I just don't like you personally. Okay. Now, historically, Congress has passed laws to protect some officials in the executive branch from being fired by the president for any reason at all. In other words, they would say, well, this kind of person can only be fired or removed for certain reasons, like they're convicted of a crime or they are obviously incompetent, right? Okay.
So this happens when Congress has decided it would be a good idea for this official to have some independence, to be able to stay in their position, even if the current president disagrees with them. And the constitutional issue is whether that interferes with the president's Article 2 authority. This matters now because the Roberts Court has been chipping away at this idea of protecting these folks and giving the president more control over the executive brand. and disagreeing with Congress providing these folks with some protections. So, for instance, in 2020, the Supreme Court decided that Congress's attempt to protect the director of the Consumer Financial Protection Bureau by restricting the reasons for the president being able to fire them was an unconstitutional interference with the president's authority. So in plain English, after this case, which is called CEL law, the president can fire the CFPB
director for any reason at all. And that's why on February 1st of this year, Trump fired Rohi Chopra, who had been appointed by Biden and confirmed by the Senate. Just don't like you, you're gone. Yeah. Okay. So that's despite what Congress had tried to do, try to protect this person because they should have some independence in, you know, creating the rules and forcing the regulations to help consumers. Right, right. And now the Supreme Court is definitely not done with this issue. This Supreme Court is now considering what is very likely going to be a very important case. It asks, can Trump simply fire a member of the Federal Trade Commission, the FTC, even though Congress has tried, through legislation, to provide some protection for commissioners of the FTC? Now, if the Supreme Court decides to allow Trump to do this, this means trouble not just for the FTC, but the job protections for many other federal commissioners.
and boards that are within the executive branch. These are the agencies meant to protect consumers, workers, the environment, all kinds of things. So what is the argument that Trump can do this, you know, when they were specifically designed to be independent and laws were passed to ensure their independence? Yeah. So in one way, it's not just Trump, right? It's a longstanding conservative movement that was building long before Trump assumed office. But the conservative argument and Trump's argument is that everybody, every single person within
the executive branch should be within the control of the president. Otherwise, they're totally unaccountable. Now, I mean, that's kind of silly, right? Because they're accountable in lots of different ways, but that's the conservative argument. And it's one that the Supreme Court might adopt in this case that I've mentioned. And it's pretty clear that the Supreme Court is very interested in this question, because this is not the only case that they are considering this term. This term, the Supreme Court, will also consider whether Trump can fire a member of the Federal Reserve, Lisa Cook. She had been appointed by Biden for a 14-year term, which is the regular term, right?
But Trump said, I want to fire you, right? Yeah, yeah. So one of the big problems here is that you have a conservative majority on the court. And remember, the Roberts Court has been around now for 20 years, right? The conservative majority on the Roberts Court wants to be protective of a very particular view of presidential power. Let presidents fire agency heads whenever they want and fill them with the choices of whatever they want, right? Yeah. On the other hand, when agencies in a democratic administration issue decisions, they also seem to be targets for the Supreme Court to say, oh, no, no, you're not allowed to do that, right? You've exceeded your powers. So it turns out that agencies can't win either way.
Either they do things that the Supreme Court says, you've exceeded your authority, or when they try to be working within that power, then a Republican president, Trump, will say, well, I don't like these policies, you're fired. So the Supreme Court really just seems to be saying everything is within the control of the president. And the president can dictate everything that happens within the executive branch. Okay. Okay. So we saw this, like, you know, in terms of the agency stuff, we saw this during the height of the pandemic with the court striking down vaccine mandates, the eviction moratorium, even expanded student loan forgiveness was something that really got its start from the inability of borrowers to pay during the worst part of the pandemic. Those are a series of agency actions. Biden, during his administration, wanted these things to happen.
Even they began with Trump too, right? But nope, for the Supreme Court, that was too much for an agency to do. And so agency power seems to be attacked from every single angle under the Roberts Court theory of, you know, how the executive branch should be run. Is there consistency in the decisions, you know, of that set of things of what an agency can do? Or does that seem to be dependent on who the president is? Seems to be strangely dependent on who the president is, right? Because, well, you know, a Republican president tends to roll back regulations. That doesn't seem to be a problem for the Supreme Court.
But in a Democratic administration, an agency that tends to provide more enforcement, more regulation, that always turns out to be a bridge too far. Not always, but often. And, of course, the blame is, well, why are you doing this extreme set of regulation? Congress didn't allow you to do this, or if Congress wanted you to do this, they should be more specific. Of course, Congress made the choice to give these agencies a lot of power. Maybe it wasn't this particular Congress, but it was the institutional body of Congress that said, well, we don't really know what we're doing. let's give the authority to the agency. So you said that there were a set of laws that were passed by Congress to establish kind of
independence and term limits for all these different agencies and to have that kind of control. And through these cases, is the Supreme Court determining that all of those laws are basically unconstitutional and thus far just haven't been tested? Well, not necessarily that the agencies themselves are unlawful, but just that the president has total control over the person at the top of these agencies or, increasingly a form of agency authority that folks had thought were more protected or in less danger were multi-member boards that had staggered terms often with bipartisan membership and that board was supposed to outlast any one particular presidential term well it seems like
even that too is going to be vulnerable in some way if the Supreme Court during this term is going to be cutting away at those protections even further yeah yeah And that just means that, of course, whatever an agency does, you just get whipsawed every time there's a new administration. Right, right. I mean, there has been this notion of building these agencies out to be apolitical bodies in a certain way, to have a certain consistency in mission and execution and follow through and vision that would, you know, maybe be shaped by a president somewhat in the agenda of a president, but wouldn't completely be altered. And, you know, depending on who the president was. And it seems like now the Supreme Court wants all these agencies to basically just be arms of the president and follow the whims of the president, the current president. Well, that's right.
And particularly if you have a president who decides in the case of Trump in a second term that some agencies just shouldn't be agencies. There's not much to argue about if you completely got the agency. You know, there's no argument about this has gone too far. The agency basically is so crippled that it can't do any work. Well, we have to take a quick break, but when we come back, on to Section 3 of Article 2. Section 3 talks about the duties of the president. And, of course, we've talked before in a previous episode about the Take Care Clause. Article 2 says the president.
Can I ask you a quick question? Sure. I've asked you this probably years and years ago. who is the person who decides what the names of the clauses are? You know, like, the take care clause is one thing. Like, I know that it's language brought it out. But, like, you know, like, you could call it the faithfully executed clause. Exactly.
Or, you know, instead of the vested clause, it could be the power clause. Or it could be, you know, like, who's the one who, like, who starts that convention and then who picks it up and determines that that is what you call a clause? That's a great question. I don't know. it just becomes kind of like tribal knowledge of people who work in con law, you know, like everybody, every, every society has its argo, has its lingo, its slang. And like for in constitutional law, that's the slang, right? We know you're not part of the in group. If you don't know, it's called the Take Care Clause. That's the way I'd put it, right. I just wonder who is the, what was the first clause named in the Constitution, you know? Yeah. Not sure, but definitely, you're right. They each have specific names. So this is the Take Care Clause. The president shall take care that the laws be faithfully executed. Interestingly enough, this is not in the part of the powers of the president. It's one of their duties, right?
或者，你知道的，除了归属条款（vested clause），它也可以叫权力条款。或者也可以是，你知道的，比如，究竟是谁发起那个惯例，然后又是谁挑选并认定这就是你所谓的那个条款的？这真是个好问题。我不知道。这只是成了宪法法学界的一种类似部落知识的东西，你知道的，就像每个人、每个社会都有自己的行话、切口、俚语一样。而在宪法法学里，那就是俚语，对吧？如果你不知道它叫“依法执行条款”（Take Care Clause），我们就知道你不是圈内人。这就是我想表达的方式，对吧。我只是在想，宪法中第一个被命名的条款究竟是谁、是什么，你知道吗？是的。不太确定，但肯定的，你说得对。它们都有特定的名称。所以这就是“依法执行条款”。总统应负责使法律得到忠实执行。有趣的是，这并不在总统权力的部分。这是他们的职责之一，对吧？
It's both an emphasis that the executive branch enforces the law. That's the will of Congress. And it's a type of constraint, too, that the president isn't allowed to legislate in any form, right? Now, if you think about the president can't legislate, that's sort of basic high school civic stuff. But what about executive orders? Oh, you've heard of those. Right, right. Yeah, they certainly feel like legislation.
这既是一种强调，即行政部门负责执行法律。那是国会的意志。同时它也是一种限制，即总统在任何形式上都不被允许进行立法，对吧？现在，如果你想到总统不能立法，这可以说是基本的高中公民课知识。但是行政命令呢？哦，你听说过那些。对吧，对吧。是的，它们确实感觉像是立法。
Right, but Article 2 says nothing about executive orders. Wow. And Congress has no general federal statute that says, hey, president, you can issue executive orders. Nevertheless, it's still generally accepted that presidents have the authority to issue some executive orders. Now, usually executive orders are directed at executive officials within the executive branch. So it's kind of like the president telling the members of the executive branch. what to do. So if they're not in here, how are they legal? And why can't the Supreme Court come and just like just completely invalidate every executive order that's ever been given?
对，但第二条对行政命令闭口不谈。哇。而且国会也没有任何普遍的联邦成文法说，嘿，总统，你可以发布行政命令。尽管如此，人们仍然普遍接受总统有权发布某些行政命令。现在，通常行政命令是针对行政部门内部的行政官员的。所以这有点像总统在告诉行政部门的成员该做什么。所以如果它们不在这里，它们怎么会是合法的？为什么最高法院不能介入，然后就像彻底废除有史以来颁布的每一项行政命令一样呢？
Well, who knows at this point? They could do that. But to be legal, a president's executive order either comes from Congress giving the president some power under a federal law, or alternatively, the power can come from the president saying, I'm just using my article two power. So for the first example, in Trump's first term, remember he issued a proclamation called 9-645 that was also known as the Muslim travel man. That was denying entry into the United States of folks from several majority Muslim countries. And the Supreme Court upheld Trump's executive order. And its reason was that Congress, when it passed the Immigration and Nationality Act, gave Trump broad authority about when and whether to suspend the entry of non-citizens.
嗯，谁知道现在情况会怎样？他们当然可以这么做。但要使其合法，总统的行政命令要么源于国会根据某项联邦法律赋予总统的某些权力，或者换句话说，这种权力可以来自总统说，我只是在行使我的第二条权力。举个第一个例子，在特朗普的第一任期内，还记得他发布了一项名为 9-645 号的公告吗，它也被称为穆斯林旅行禁令。那是拒绝来自几个穆斯林人口占多数的国家的民众入境美国。最高法院维持了特朗普的行政命令。其理由是，国会在通过《移民和国籍法》时，赋予了特朗普关于何时以及是否暂停非公民入境的广泛权力。
And of course, Trump was doing just that, maybe for improper, subjectively horrible reasons, but he was simply doing what Congress allowed him to do. So the court says, that's an okay executive order. As for an executive order that is based on constitutional authority, Truman gives us an example. When Truman desegregated the armed forces in 1948, he did so through an executive order.
当然，特朗普当时做的正是这件事，也许是出于不当的、主观上糟糕的理由，但他做的仅仅是国会允许他做的事。所以法院说，这是一个合法的行政命令。至于基于宪法权力的行政命令，杜鲁门给我们提供了一个例子。杜鲁门在 1948 年对武装部队进行种族隔离时，就是通过行政命令完成的。
Yeah. And how did he do that? He said his authority came not just from federal statutes, but from his authority as commander-in-chief. Right, right. That makes the most sense to me. Yeah. Anything within the military makes the most sense to me. Right.
是的。他是怎么做到的？他说他的权力不仅来自联邦成文法，还来自他作为三军统帅的权力。对，对。这对我来说最合乎逻辑。对。军事范畴内的任何事情对我来说都最合乎逻辑。对。
Yeah. Now, a big aspect of Trump's second term is just the sheer number of executive orders that he has issued. So to give you a sense, in his first term, Trump issued 220 executive orders total. So far, it's just December of 2025, in his second term, Trump has issued at least, I think, 218, that was as of October. And, of course, the first year isn't even over yet. And I know there was another one just yesterday. Some of these are just ordinary or they seem to be symbolic.
是的。现在，特朗普第二任期的一个大特点就是他发布的行政命令数量极其庞大。为了让你有个概念，在第一任期内，特朗普总共发布了 220 项行政命令。到目前为止，现在才 2025 年 12 月，在他的第二任期内，特朗普已经发布了至少，我想是 218 项，那是截至 10 月的数据。而且，当然，第一年甚至还没过完。我知道就在昨天又有一项出台了。其中一些只是常规的，或者看起来具有象征意义。
But others have tried to dramatically change how we understand how the federal government works. So targeting law firms that represent Democrats, ending climate and energy initiatives. freezing foreign aid, and, of course, ending birthright citizenship. Now, just because the present issues an executive order doesn't mean it's legal, of course, and dozens of Trump's executive orders have already been challenged in court. So how can an order be challenged, then? Well, the easiest way is when a later president revokes the executive order. So, like, a succeeding president just says all of that is undone.
但另一些则试图彻底改变我们对联邦政府运作方式的理解。比如针对代表民主党的律师事务所、终止气候和能源倡议、冻结对外援助，当然，还有终止出生公民权。现在，当然，总统发布行政命令并不意味着它就是合法的，特朗普的许多行政命令已经在法庭上受到挑战。那么，一项命令究竟该如何受到挑战呢？嗯，最简单的方法就是后任总统废除前任的行政命令。比如，继任的总统直接宣布这一切全部作废。
And that happens all the time. When Biden became president, he revoked many of Trump's orders from his first term. And then when Trump became president, he revoked a huge number of Biden's orders from his term. Now, in his first two months in office, Trump revoked 91 of Biden's executive orders. That's just a lot comparatively. 67 of Biden's executive orders were revoked in one executive order. He just, like, wanted to wipe out everything that Biden had done. That was the first, actually.
这种事时发生。当拜登成为总统时，他废除了特朗普第一任期的许多命令。然后当特朗普再次成为总统时，他又废除了拜登任期内的大量命令。在上任的前两个月里，特朗普就废除了拜登的 91 项行政命令。相比之下，这数量实在太大了。拜登的 67 项行政命令在一项行政命令中就被全部废除了。他就像是想抹杀拜登做过的一切。实际上，那是第一次。
So many in one executive order. Now, Congress can't overturn. If I became president after Trump, not only would I nullify every executive order. I think I would tear down every building he touched. Well, unfortunately, that's going to be a, I'm not sure if it's a harder task or an easier next. Well, Congress can't overturn executive order because it's really something that the president is just doing.
竟然在一项行政命令里包含这么多。现在，国会无法推翻。如果我在特朗普之后当选总统，我不仅会废除每一个行政命令。我想我会拆掉他摸过的每一栋建筑。嗯，不幸的是，这将是一个，我不确定这算是一项更艰巨的任务还是接下来更简单的任务。嗯，国会不能推翻行政命令，因为这确实是总统自己正在做的事情。
But if the president is claiming that the reason why he can issue an order is because he's implementing a statute, then Congress can simply modify or negate the order by passing another law themselves. So, no, that's not what we meant at all. I see, I see. And, of course, if there's a constitutional problem, lawsuits can be filed alleging that there are legal constitutional problems with the order, right? And we've seen that, again, there are dozens of lawsuits right now. If the power to give executive orders is not in there, how do you begin to argue that he doesn't have the power to do a certain thing?
但如果总统声称他之所以能发布某项命令是因为他正在执行一项成文法，那么国会就可以通过自行通过另一项法律来修改或否定该命令。所以，不，我们根本不是那个意思。我明白，我明白。当然，如果存在宪法问题，就可以提起诉讼，声称该命令存在合法的宪法问题，对吧？我们已经看到了，再次强调，现在有几十起诉讼。如果发布行政命令的权力不在那里，你又如何开始争论他没有权力做某件特定的事情呢？
It just seems like it's all kind of weirdly in the clouds. It is. It is. But, I mean, part of constitutional practice, of course, is always history. And, you know, George Washington had an executive order. So we have lived with something that is arguably constitutional because everyone has always agreed that it's constitutional for the president to do this kind of thing, not the specific versions of them. Wow. But nevertheless, presidents are allowed to do this.
这看起来好像一切都莫名其妙地悬在空中。确实如此。确实如此。但是，我的意思是，宪法实践的一部分当然始终是历史。而且，你知道的，乔治·华盛顿就下达过行政命令。所以我们一直生活在某种可以说是合乎宪法的事情中，因为每个人一直都认为总统做这种事是合乎宪法的，虽然不是指它们的具体版本。哇。但尽管如此，总统们是被允许这样做的。
Now, in modern presidencies, unfortunately, it becomes a way for a frustrated president to try to regulate when Congress will not do so. Right, right. But they're always very temporary because the next administration will tend to modify or revoke completely many executive orders. Right. That makes sense. Yeah. So now let's step back for a moment. Article 2 tells us that the president of the United States has some very important powers that are just for the president alone.
现在，在现代总统制中，不幸的是，这成了一个受挫的总统在国会不愿采取行动时试图进行监管的一种途径。对，对。但它们总是非常短暂的，因为下一届政府往往会修改或完全废除许多行政命令。对。这说得通。是的。所以现在让我们退后一步思考。宪法第二条告诉我们，美国总统拥有一些仅属于总统的非常重要的权力。
The president has the duty to execute federal law. The president commands the armed forces. The president grants pardons, appoints officers of the United States, and negotiates treaties. the Constitution gives this one person in the federal government all of this power. So the question is, how do we ensure that the president, as Hamilton wrote in the federalist papers, is not a feeble executive? How do we make sure that the president isn't hampered too much and can act in the way that Article 2 intended?
总统有执行联邦法律的职责。总统统帅三军。总统有权赦免、任命美国官员以及谈判条约。宪法将所有这些权力赋予了联邦政府中的这一个人。所以问题是，我们如何确保总统，正如汉密尔顿在《联邦党人文集》中所写的那样，不是一个软弱的行政首脑？我们如何确保总统不会受到过多掣肘，并能按照第二条的意图行事？
Well, in 2024, of course, the Supreme Court's answer was immunity from criminal prosecution, right? So we've done an episode on this previously, but remember that in August of 2023, special counsel, Jack Smith, concluded his investigation, a federal grand jury indicted Trump, who was not president at the time, on a four-count indictment related to what happened after he lost the 2020 election, right? So this includes the fake elector scheme, pressuring state officials, attempting a sham justice department investigation, leaning on vice president Pence to change the election certification on January. six and making public statements about election fraud. So the monumental decision in Trump versus the United States was simply summarized like this. A president cannot be prosecuted for much of this conduct. Specifically for unofficial conduct, the Supreme Court said that's fine. A president can be prosecuted for things that have nothing to do with the office of the presidency. But when it comes to official conduct, the Supreme Court said that the president's official acts can be divided
嗯，当然，在 2024 年，最高法院给出的答案是刑事起诉豁免权，对吧？所以我们之前做过一集关于这个主题的节目，但请记住，在 2023 年 8 月，特别检察官杰克·史密斯结束了他的调查，一个联邦大陪审团对当时并非总统的特朗普提出了四项罪名的起诉，内容涉及他 2020 年竞选失利后发生的事情，对吧？所以这包括虚假选举人计划、向州官员施压、试图进行虚假的司法部调查、向副总统彭斯施压要求在 1 月 6 日改变选举认证结果，以及发表关于选举舞弊的公开声明。因此，在“特朗普诉美国案”中具有划时代意义的裁决可以简单概括如下。总统不能因其中许多行为而被起诉。特别是对于非官方行为，最高法院表示这没问题。总统可以因与总统职务完全无关的事情而被起诉。但当谈到官方行为时，最高法院表示总统的官方行为可以被划分为
into two parts. So it'll sort of imagine a circle. At the edge of the circle are official acts that aren't related to a core presidential power. And so there the president enjoys a presumption of immunity from prosecution that the prosecution can overcome in limited circumstances. But that included a lot of conduct, including, according to the Supreme Court, speaking to and on behalf of the American people. And at the time, that was a lot of tweeting, right? I see, I see. Right. And then there's the center of the circle. At the center of the circle, you have official conduct that the Supreme Court called core constitutional functions. What are they?
两个部分。所以你可以想象一个圆圈。圆圈的边缘是与核心总统权力无关的官方行为。因此，总统在这里享有起诉豁免权的推定，而控方在有限情况下可以推翻这种推定。但这包括了大量行为，根据最高法院的说法，包括对美国人民讲话以及代表美国人民讲话。而在当时，那涉及大量的发推特，对吧？我明白，我明白。对。然后是圆圈的中心。在圆圈的中心，则是最高法院称之为核心宪法职能的官方行为。它们是什么？
The powers that we've just talked about. The pardon power. The power to remove or fire officers of the United States. And importantly for the criminal prosecution of Trump, the investigation and prosecution of crimes. So in the Supreme Court's view, even if this was a complete bogus and sham investigation, when Trump directed the Justice Department to say, hey, look into election fraud. well that was core article two conduct therefore it can't be prosecuted even if it's based on bad faith even if it was made up and as for the other conduct that might not have enjoyed total immunity
正是我们刚才讨论过的那些权力。赦免权。罢免或解职美国官员的权力。对于特朗普的刑事起诉至关重要的则是，犯罪的调查与起诉。因此在最高法院看来，即使这是一场完全虚假和冒牌的调查，当特朗普指示司法部说，嘿，去调查选举舞弊时，嗯，那属于核心的第二条授权行为，因此不能被起诉，即使它是基于恶意，即使它是捏造的。至于其他可能并未享有完全豁免权的行为
the outer part of that circle remember the supreme court decision in trump versus the united states came out on july first 24 the court took so long in deciding the case that time ran out Trump was re-elected, and then the case disappeared. But the impact of Trump versus the United States and core Article 2 conduct is just really enormous. You know, we've talked previously about the Trump administration's use of the military for these boat strikes to blow up alleged drug smuggling boats in the Caribbean. Yeah. Well, the administration claims that they're in a war with these drug smugglers, and that's why the boats can be blown up without any process. But, of course, as we've discussed before, this doesn't seem to be a war at all.
也就是那个圆圈的外围部分，记住最高法院关于“特朗普诉美国案”的裁决是在 24 年 7 月 1 日发布的。法院在裁决此案时花了太长时间，以至于时间耗尽了，特朗普再次当选，然后这个案子就消失了。但“特朗普诉美国案”以及核心第二条授权行为的影响真的是巨大的。你知道的，我们之前讨论过特朗普政府在加勒比地区利用军队进行这些舰艇打击，以炸毁所谓的毒品走私船。是的。嗯，政府声称他们正在与这些毒品走私者交战，这就是为什么可以在没有任何正当程序的情况下炸毁这些船只的原因。但是，当然，正如我们之前讨论过的，这根本看起来不像是一场战争。
And in fact, the decision to kill without arrest or trial has been characterized by many serious legal analysts as murder, just plain simple murder. So what if it is murder? After all, Trump is the commander-in-chief under Article 2. Well, I think the pretty clear answer from the 2024 decision is that as long as Trump is exercising a core Article 2 constitutional power, he himself cannot be criminally prosecuted. even if the evidence suggests that these boat strikes amount to murder. Does that mean everyone around him is immune as well? No, this was only a decision about the president himself. Okay.
事实上，这种未经逮捕或审判就将其杀害的决定，被许多严肃的法律分析人士定性为谋杀，纯粹的、简单的谋杀。那么如果是谋杀又怎样？毕竟，根据第二条，特朗普是三军统帅。嗯，我认为 2024 年的裁决给出的相当明确的答案是，只要特朗普在行使核心的第二条宪法权力，他本人就不能被刑事起诉，即使有证据表明这些舰艇打击构成了谋杀。这是否意味着他周围的每个人也同样享有豁免权？不，这只是一项针对总统本人的裁决。好吧。
Yeah. So everyone around him could go down for murder and he would stand alone as the person was on. I mean, possibly. I mean, of course, the Supreme Court was only deciding the question of president. Yeah. It's just interesting. Yeah. Also, there was that crazy hypothetical from the immunity case. Before the case was actually decided by the Supreme Court, one of the,
是的。所以他身边的所有人可能会因为谋杀而倒台，而他将作为唯一被起诉的人孤立无援。我的意思是，有可能。当然，最高法院当时只裁决了关于总统的问题。是的。这真有趣。是的。此外，豁免权案中还有一个极其疯狂的假设。在最高法院对该案做出裁决之前，其中一位
the judges on the appeals court panel raised this seal team six hypothetical um seal team six is that elite group of navy seals that carry out um high stakes military missions right um judge florence pan who was on the appeals court in dc asked trump's lawyer could a president order seal team six to assassinate a political rival that's an official act trump's lawyer john sour would not give a direct answer well the washington post reported at the end of november who carried out the boat strikes seal team same six, right? It's just a weird, hypothetical come to real life. Wow. And then there's Section 4 of Article 2. That is impeachment. Section 4 is supposed to be a remedy, right? It tells us that the president, the vice president, and all civil officers of the United States shall be
上诉法院小组的法官提出了这个海豹突击队第六分队的假设，嗯，海豹突击队第六分队是那个执行高风险军事任务的精锐海军陆战队特种部队，对吧？嗯，曾在华盛顿特区上诉法院任职的法官弗洛伦斯·潘询问特朗普的律师：总统能否下令海豹突击队第六分队暗杀政治对手？那是一项官方行为吗？特朗普的律师约翰·萨尔拒绝给出直接回答。嗯，《华盛顿邮报》在 11 月底报道说，执行舰艇打击的是谁？正是海豹突击队第六分队，对吧？这只是一种奇怪的假设变成了现实。哇。接下来是第二条第四款。也就是弹劾。第四款本应是一种救济措施，对吧？它告诉我们，总统、副总统和美国所有文职官员应当在
removed from office on impeachment for and conviction of treason, bribery, or other high crimes and misdemeanors. In 2021, President Trump became the only president in American history to be impeached twice and, in fact, in the same term. The first impeachment trial arose from the call he made to a Ukrainian president, Zelensky, which he was apparently offering to unfreeze military aid if Zelensky would investigate Joe Biden and promote this bogus theory that Russia was not behind the foreign interference in the 2016 election. And the second impeachment trial accused Trump of incitement to insurrection over the January
因叛国罪、贿赂罪或其他严重罪行和轻罪而被弹劾并定罪时被罢免职务。2021 年，特朗普总统成为美国历史上唯一一位被弹劾两次、而且事实上是在同一任期内被弹劾两次的总统。第一次弹劾审判源于他打给乌克兰总统泽连斯基的电话，他在电话中显然表示，如果泽连斯基调查乔·拜登并宣扬俄罗斯并非2026年境外干预幕后黑手的虚假理论，他就会解冻军事援助。而第二次弹劾审判则指控特朗普因 1 月 6 日国会山袭击事件而煽动叛乱。在两次参议院审判中，特朗普当然都被判无罪。所以我想今天的主要结论是，当涉及到第二条时，毫无疑问，特朗普作为总统、前总统以及现在再次成为总统，对我们如何看待第二条留下了深刻的印记。是的。而罗伯茨法院也带来了对第二条完全不同的看法。没错。是的。嗯，这些都是引人入胜的内容。
6th capital attack. In both Senate trials, Trump was, of course, acquitted. So I think the main takeaway here today is that when there's Article 2, there's no question that Trump, as a president, as an ex-president, and now a president again, has left a definitive mark about how we think about Article 2. Yeah. And the Roberts Court has also led to a completely different view of Article 2. That's right. Yeah. Well, this is fascinating stuff.
我很高兴我们能更深入地探讨第二条。拥有特朗普总统来引导我们度过这个探索时刻是多么幸运啊。我们已经撑过了一年。我们将看看明年会发生什么。我的意思是，我甚至不知道。我甚至不知道。接下来我们将与前疾控中心主任汤姆·弗里登博士进行对话。现在是我们与医师兼公共卫生专家汤姆·弗里登博士的对话。
I'm so glad we went through Article 2 in greater depth. And what great fortune is to have President Trump to guide us through this moment of exploration. We have survived one year. We'll see what happens next year. I mean, I don't even know. I don't even know. Coming up our conversation with former CDC director, Dr. Tom Frieden. Now our conversation with Dr. Tom Frieden, a physician and public health expert.
今天他是全球健康非营利组织“拯救生命”（Resolve to Save Lives）的执行董事，也是新书《更好健康的公式：如何拯救数百万生命，包括你自己的生命》（The Formula for Better Health, How to Save Millions of Lives, including your own）的作者。在奥巴马总统任内的 2009 年至 2017 年期间，他是第 16 任疾病控制与预防中心主任，这使他成为疾控中心历史上任职第二长的负责人。在此之前，弗里登博士于 2002 年至 2009 年在布隆伯格市长手下担任纽约市公共卫生局局长，因此他同时拥有城市和联邦层面的经验。弗里登博士，非常感谢您来到节目中。很高兴加入你们。所以第二条确立了行政部门，并假定总统将拥有一个
Today he's the executive director of the global health nonprofit resolved to save lives and author of the recent book, The Formula for Better Health, How to Save Millions of Lives, including your own. He was the 16th director of the Centers for Disease Control and Prevention under President Obama from 2009 to 2017, which makes him the second long. longest serving head in the CDC's history. Before that, Dr. Frieden was the New York City Public Health Commissioner under Mayor Bloomberg from 2002 to 2009, so he has experience at both the city and the federal level. Dr. Frieden, thank you so much for being on the show. Great to join you. So Article 2 establishes the executive branch and assumes that the president will have a
内阁，但第二条的起草者没有预料到的是我们所谓的行政国家的膨胀，即今天联邦政府中许许多多的机构，它们监管着从安全可食用的食物、清洁可饮用的水，到公平的工作条件、再到对消费者诚实的商业行为等方方面面。疾病控制与预防中心大约是隶属于卫生与公众服务部的十几个机构之一。疾控中心的起源可以追溯到 1942 年。这是一段相当有趣的历史。它曾是一个战时机构，名为“战区疟疾控制办公室”，并于 1946 年更名为“传染病中心”，然后在 1980 年成为“疾病控制中心”。
cabinet, but what the drafters of Article 2 did not contemplate is the growth of what we call the administrative state, the many, many agencies in the federal government today that regulate everything from food that is safe to eat and water that is clean to drink, working conditions that are fair, corporate behavior that is honest for consumers. The Centers for Disease Control and Prevention is one of the roughly dozen agencies housed within the Department of Health and Human Services. The origins of the CDC go back to 1942. It's a pretty interesting history. It was a wartime agency called the Office of Malaria Control in war areas, and it became Communicable Disease Center in 1946, and then Centers for Disease Control in 1980.
部分由于这些不同寻常的起源，疾控中心从不同的来源获取其权力。国会直接赋予了疾控中心部分权力，但疾控中心的一些权力是由卫生与公众服务部部长以及外科医生总长（Surgeon General）下放给它的。例如，疾控中心有权发布隔离令，因为这些权力是由外科医生总长下放给它的，而外科医生总长反过来又是从 1944 年的《联邦公共卫生服务法》中获得了这些权力。所以这是长话短说，为疾控中心那些宪法权力的来源做了一个小小的开场白。所以弗里登博士，我希望你能给我们讲讲，这个机构最初是为了阻止疟疾在军中传播，但它现在所做的事情远不止于此。你能描述一下今天疾控中心的宗旨吗？很简单，疾控中心传统上所做的工作就是全天候 24 小时保护美国人免受威胁。
In part, because of those unusual origins, the CDC acquires its powers from different sources. Congress has directly given the CDC some of its powers, but some of the CDC's powers have been delegated to it from the Secretary of Health and Human Services and from the Surgeon General. For example, the CDC has the power to issue quarantine orders because it has been delegated those powers by the Surgeon General, who in turn was given those powers from the Federal Public Health Service Act of 1944. So it's a long way of talking, giving a little bit of a preamble of where those sort of constitutional powers of the CDC come from. So Dr. Frieden, I'm hoping you can tell us this agency, you know, began as a way to stop malaria from spreading among the military, but it does so much more than that now. Could you describe the objectives of the CDC today? Quite simply, what the CDC has traditionally done is to work 24-7 to protect Americans from threats.
无论这些威胁是自然的还是人造的，无论是传染病还是其他什么，无论它们来自美国还是世界任何地方。这就是核心底线。让人们更健康、更安全。因此，疾控中心和整个联邦政府在 2020 年面临着新冠大流行的巨大健康威胁。在特朗普政府的第一任期内，疾控中心并没有免受政治压力的影响，并且存在很多批评，专家们批评了对风险的不同计算方式。当谈到这个机构时，它属于行政部门，因此
Whether those threats are natural or man-made, whether they are infectious diseases or otherwise, whether they come from the United States or anywhere in the world. That's the bottom line. Healthier, safer people. So the CDC and the entire federal government faced a gigantic health threat in 2020 with the COVID pandemic. And during that first term of the Trump administration, the CDC wasn't insulated from political pressure and there were a lot of criticism, experts criticized, the different sort of calculation of risk. When it comes to this agency, which is within the executive branch and therefore
有点像受总统管辖，但它拥有自己的专业知识、自己的指南以及对事物的看法，对于像疾控中心这样的机构来说，在回应总统可能想要的东西与对公共卫生最有利的事情之间，正确的平衡点是什么？我回过头来。我回过头来。我回过头来，探讨这里的几个核心概念。政府分析师和思想家詹姆斯·Q·威尔逊等人曾探讨过什么是专业人士的定义。专业人士是指这样一个人，他拥有独立于其所在组织的指挥线、控制线之外的标准。因此，作为一名医生，如果我在一个组织工作，而我的主管说，给出这种药或做这项检查，而这与我的职业责任不符，
sort of like under the president, but has its own expertise and its own guidelines and its own thoughts on things, what is the right balance for agency like the CDC to respond to what the president might want versus what is best for public health? I go back. I go back. I go back, to a couple of core concepts here. The analyst and thinker about government, James Q. Wilson and others have talked about what is the definition of a professional? And a professional is someone who has standards that are outside of the line of control, the line of command of their group. So as a physician, if I'm working in an organization and my supervisor says, give this medicine or get this test, and that's inconsistent with my professional responsibility,
我必须说不，否则我就违背了同样的职业责任。同样，疾控中心试图提供清晰、一致、以事实为依据的信息，明确指出这是我们知道的，这是我们不知道的，这是我们如何知道我们所知道的。需要理解的第二件大事，我认为政治分歧各方的许多人都搞错了，那就是疾控中心的作用不是制定政策。疾控中心的作用是为那些制定政策的人提供信息。如果你做甲，你就会得到乙。这真的很重要，因为例如，如果你谈论像口罩这样的事情，如果每个人在新冠病毒广泛传播时都在室内佩戴口罩，新冠病毒的传播就会减少。这并不是说每个人都应该一直在室内戴口罩
I have to say no, or I have to violate my professional responsibility. In the same way, the CDC tries to provide clear, consistent, fact-based information, making clear this is what we know, this is what we don't know, this is how we know what we know. And the second big thing to understand that I think a lot of people have gotten wrong on all sides of the political divide is that the CDC's role is not to set policy. The CDC's role is to inform those who set policy. If you do X, you will get Y. This is really important because, for example, if you talk about something like masks, if everyone wears masks indoors when COVID is spreading, widely, there will be less spread of COVID. That's not saying that everyone should wear masks
，或者我们应该关闭所有的餐馆，或者我们应该关闭酒吧。我们认为这最好留给社区，通过社区讨论和该社区的民选领导人来决定。所以我认为一个基于科学的组织的本质是，它以开放和客观得出的最佳可用科学证据为基础，提供有效的信息。疾控中心最引人注目的部分之一是来自该机构的建议，这些建议可以是从疫苗指南到医院和医生办公室的手部卫生等方方面面的内容。这种关于建议的交流是单向的，还是疾控中心确定的建议被提交给政策制定者，然后政策制定者说，嗯，你知道的，这是可能的，这不是可能的，这是可行的，这
indoors all the time, or we should close all the restaurants, or we should close the bars. This is something that we think is best left to communities to decide with a community discussion and elected leaders of that community. So I think the essence of a science-based organization is that it provides valid information based on the best available scientific evidence openly and objectively derived. One of the most visible parts of the CDC is recommendations that come from the agency, and these can be anything from vaccine guidelines to hand hygiene in hospitals and doctors' offices. Is that communication for recommendations one way, or is the recommendation for what the CDC has determined put forward to policymakers and the policymakers? makers go, well, you know, this is possible, this is not possible, this is feasible, this is
是不可行的，然后你们带着这个认识重新调整你们的模型，然后共同拿出一个类似的东西？还是它真的只是一种单向交流，即你们提出建议，然后他们认为合适就去实施？对话的更大一部分是与那些最熟悉特定主题事实的人进行的，以探讨：哪些是有指征的，哪些是没有指征的？有时这很简单明了。你知道的，如果你想降低婴儿猝死综合征（SIDS）的风险，让你的孩子仰睡。
not feasible, and then you go, you know, rejigger your models with that in mind and then sort of come up with a sort of thing together? Or is it really just a one-way communication where you present proposals and then they implement it as they see fit? The larger part of the dialogue is with the people who are most familiar with the facts about specific topics to say, you know, what is indicated, what is not indicated? Sometimes it's plain and simple. You know, put your child on their back to sleep if you want to reduce the risk of SIDS.
很简单明了。而在其他时候，证据并不那么明确，无论是关于营养还是体育活动。你知道的，剧烈体育活动有多重要？体育活动的最低剂量是多少？这些都是复杂的话题。所以我觉得当涉及到政策选择或建议选择时，
Straightforward. Other times, the evidence isn't so clear, whether it's about nutrition or physical activity. You know, how important is vigorous physical activity? What's the minimum dose of physical activity? These are complicated topics. So I think when it comes to policy choices or recommendation choices,
更广泛的对话既在疾控中心内部展开，也在疾控中心与卫生与公众服务部的其他部门、联邦政府的其他部门、学术界、倡导者和其他各方之间展开，以了解什么才是真正的事实，从而得出最有效的政策建议。在政策实施方面，那是另一种不同的
the bigger dialogue is both within CDC and among CDC and other parts of the Department of Health and Human Services, other parts of the federal government, academia, advocates, and others to understand what's really the fact here that's going to lead to policy recommendation that will be most effective. In terms of policy implementation, that's kind of a different. science. That may involve Congress allocating money and saying, okay, CDC, give money to states and cities to implement this program if they choose to do so or in the way they choose to do so. Occasionally, you'll get a program that uses those federal dollars to incentivize localities to have healthier policies. And the classic example of that, not part of CDC, but federal government is a road safety where the states were free to take or not take the federal dollars.
科学。这可能涉及国会拨款并表示，好吧，疾控中心，把钱给各州和城市，让它们选择实施这个程序，或者以它们选择的方式实施。偶尔，你会看到一个项目利用这些联邦资金来激励地方制定更健康的政策。而这方面的经典例子，虽不属于疾控中心，但属于联邦政府，那就是道路安全，各州可以自由接受或不接受联邦资金。
But if they took the federal dollars, they needed to reduce the blood alcohol concentration and go to lower speed limits for a while. Yeah. Right. So I think one of the things that is sometimes confusing to the public is, well, maybe I do want to rely on expertise, but who's expertise? So if we turn to the current administration, there's been a complete overturning of ASIP, the committee that advises the CDC on immunization.
但如果他们接受了联邦资金，他们就需要降低血液酒精浓度并在一段时间内实行较低的限速。是的。对吧。所以我想公众有时会感到困惑的一点是，好吧，也许我确实想依靠专业知识，但那是谁的专业知识？如果我们转向现任政府，对咨询疾控中心免疫接种问题的委员会 ASIP 进行了彻底的颠覆。
All of the former members were removed by HHS Secretary Kennedy, and there are new ones. But if you look at the list, if I'm a member of the public, I think, well, they seem to be well credentialed. So maybe you could explain what is the difference between being well credentialed and actually being able to provide reliable expert advice on something like vaccines? I think we have a challenging situation in this country where the word expert has become a dirty word. And I think part of that is because people don't want someone saying, I'm the expert and I know what you should do. That's very offensive.
所有前任成员都被卫生与公众服务部部长肯尼迪撤换了，并换上了新成员。但如果你看一下名单，如果我是一个普通公众，我会想，嗯，他们似乎都有很好的资历。所以也许你可以解释一下，拥有良好资历与真正能够就疫苗等事情提供可靠专家建议之间有什么区别？我认为我们在这个国家面临着一种具有挑战性的情况，“专家”这个词已经变成了一个贬义词。我认为部分原因是人们不希望有人说，“我是专家，我知道你应该怎么做。”这非常冒犯。
So I always start with saying, you are the experts in you. But what science can do is it can tell you if you want to achieve. something health-wise, we can tell you what's proven, what's unproven. And I think when it comes to levels of certainty, it's really important to understand that there are highly specialized areas where there are things that are virtually certain, not such a hard thing. Where there are things where it's no evidence, not so hard. It's in that gray zone where it's so important, even in areas where just to say I'm
所以我总是从这句话开始：你们才是关于你们自己的专家。但科学能做到的是，它可以告诉你，如果你想在健康方面达成某种目标，我们可以告诉你什么是经过证实的，什么是未经证实的。我认为当涉及到确定性水平时，非常重要的一点是我们要明白，有一些高度专业化的领域，那里存在着几乎可以确定的事情，这并不算太难。有些领域则是毫无证据的，这也不算太难。正是在那个灰色地带，这一点变得如此重要，甚至在那些仅仅是说我
I work a huge proportion of my time on one particular health issue. A new article comes out on that. I'm still not the best person to understand whether that article is valid. I know who I can go to, who are people who have worked on this for whole lifetimes. And that's one of the things that CDC is so wonderful about or has been so wonderful about. There are people there. if you opened a medical textbook to any random page, there have been people there who would be able to tell you,
将我绝大部分的时间都花在一个特定健康问题上的领域也是如此。一篇关于该主题的新文章发表了。我依然不是理解该文章是否有效最佳人选。我知道我可以求助于谁，那些一辈子都在研究这个领域的人。这就是疾控中心如此美妙的地方之一，或者说曾经如此美妙的地方。那里有这样的人：如果你把一本医学教科书翻到任意随机的一页，那里都会有人能够告诉你，
oh, here's what's really important about that topic. And people have asked me, do I miss being CDC director? And what I miss is when an article comes out in the New England Journal of Medicine or some other newspaper or a medical journal, I could call up one of the world's experts in that area and say, you know, what's the real deal here? So that kind of expertise is deep expertise. And, you know, there is something called Brandolini's Law
哦，关于这个话题真正重要的是什么。曾有人问我，我想念担任疾控中心主任的日子吗？而我想念的是，当《新英格兰医学杂志》或其他报纸或医学期刊上发表文章时，我可以打电话给该领域的全球顶尖专家之一，然后说，你知道的，这背后的真实情况是什么？所以这种专业知识是深厚的专业知识。而且，你知道的，有一种叫做布兰多尼定律（Brandolini's Law）的说法
that it takes infinitely longer to debunk nonsense than to spread it. And I've seen this, for example, with some of the things that RFK Jr. is saying. For example, he recorded a three-minute video when he announced that the U.S. is pulling out of the Global Vaccine Alliance, what's called Gavi. And this is a terrible mistake. This means that lots of kids may die of preventable disease.
即驳斥胡言乱语所需的时间要无限长于散布它所需的时间。我见过这种情况，例如罗伯特·F·肯尼迪（RFK Jr.）所说的一些话。例如，当他宣布美国退出全球疫苗联盟（即 Gavi）时，他录制了一段三分钟的视频。这是一个可怕的错误。这意味着许多儿童可能会死于可预防的疾病。
The U.S. may be at greater risk if these diseases spread and come here because we can't keep diseases out. Viruses don't need visas. And in this three-minute video, he had multiple falsehoods. And some of them, I understood the issue well enough to understand why it was a falsehood. But there was one that was, you know, really complicated. He said, oh, this vaccine increases the deaths of children. And it took me days to track down the article. He mentioned an article.
如果这些疾病蔓延并来到我们这里，美国可能会面临更大的风险，因为我们无法将疾病拒之门外。病毒不需要签证。在这段三分钟的视频中，他包含了几处虚假陈述。其中一些，我对这个问题的理解足够深刻，能够明白为什么它是虚假的。但其中有一个，你知道的，真的很复杂。他说，哦，这种疫苗增加了儿童的死亡率。我花了几天时间才追踪到那篇文章。他提到了一篇文章。
And then no one gets promoted in their university for debunking a bad article, right? So this article was in the literature for years. You know, it had been criticized in a kind of gentle way. But it took a couple of days to look carefully and understand, oh, it's got a fundamental methodological flaw. where the unvaccinated girls also had unrecorded deaths. So it looked like not vaccinating these girls resulted in saving their lives. But what it really showed was that the girls were neither accessing health care to get vaccines nor having their deaths recorded.
而且没有人会因为驳斥了一篇糟糕的文章而在大学里获得晋升，对吧？所以这篇文章在文献中存在了多年。你知道的，它曾以一种温和的方式受到批评。但我们花了几天时间仔细研究并理解，哦，它有一个根本性的方法论缺陷。其中未接种疫苗的女孩也存在未记录的死亡。所以看起来不给这些女孩接种疫苗反而成了拯救她们生命的结果。但它真正显示的是，这些女孩既没有获得医疗保健以接种疫苗，她们的死亡也没有被记录在案。
So sometimes it's very hard to track down the reality amid a blizzard of falsehoods. Yeah. Yeah. It's also not just falsehood, but also like the difference between certainty and uncertainty. Science lives very comfortably in uncertainty. And politics does not. And when you're talking about something, you know, this professional list of principles, you know, I loved hearing them. They are not shared with necessarily a political body. And so when those things have to interact and necessarily they do have to interact, you know, what is the friction of that outcome? I think that's a really important point. And partly it has to do with science education, partly it has to do with encouraging people to embrace nuance in our lives. I was part of a focus group with people who are reluctant to get vaccinated, and several of them kept saying, just tell me the bottom line.
所以有时在一片虚假信息的风雪中追踪真相是非常困难的。是的。是的。这不仅是虚假信息，而且还涉及到确定性与不确定性之间的差异。科学非常安于不确定性。而政治则不然。当你谈论某事时，你知道的，这种专业原则列表，你知道的，我很喜欢听它们。它们不一定与政治机构共享。所以当这些东西必须互动而且它们必然必须互动时，你知道的，那种结果会产生什么样的摩擦？我认为这是一个非常重要的观点。部分原因与科学教育有关，部分原因与鼓励人们在生活中拥抱细微差别有关。我曾参与过一个针对不愿接种疫苗人群的焦点小组讨论，其中几个人一直说，直接告诉我底线是什么。
And the bottom line is that it changes over time. And that's why communication is so important, that we are really clear with people what do we know, how do we know it? What do we not know? What are we doing to try to find it out? And based on what we know now, and this may change, this is what we recommend, and to have some degree of certainty in that. There's an interesting paradox when it comes to public health in that sort of step, is
而底线是它会随着时间而改变。这就是为什么沟通如此重要，我们要向人们真正明确：我们知道什么？我们是如何知道的？我们不知道什么？我们正在做些什么来试图找出答案？根据我们现在所知道的——这可能会改变——这就是我们的建议，并且对此抱有一定的确定性。在公共卫生领域存在一个有趣的悖论，那就是
that any appropriate action when it actually prevents something will feel like an overreaction because it has prevented the thing that it was in terms. tending to prevent. How do you get people to believe in a preventative action doing its job when the result is things are going along swimmingly and they don't, you know, like if it's doing, when government is working well and when the CEC is working well, people should not notice its existence, but you need them to notice its existence for it to continue healthfully. Like, what, how do you deal with that? My organization resolved to save lives produces a periodic report called epidemics that didn't happen,
任何适当的行动，当它确实阻止了某事时，都会让人感觉像是过度反应，因为它阻止了它原本想要阻止的事情。当一切顺风顺水、他们并没有（例如，如果它正在起作用的话），你如何让人们相信预防性行动在发挥作用呢？当政府运作良好、疾控中心运作良好时，人们不应该注意到它的存在，但你需要他们注意到它的存在，它才能健康地持续下去。比如，你怎么处理这个问题？我的组织“拯救生命”定期发布一份名为《未发生的流行病》（Epidemics that Didn't Happen）的报告，
where we highlight the great work of a team of doctors, nurses, public health specialists somewhere in the world that stopped an epidemic that we never heard about. And part of it is emphasizing the progress. It's part of human nature to kind of take for granted the things that aren't problems. And yes, public health generally is not recognized because when we succeed, nothing happens. And when we fail, it's headline news. Now, of course, then there are also epidemics that do happen.
我们在其中重点介绍了世界上某地的一支医生、护士和公共卫生专家团队的出色工作，他们阻止了一场我们从未听说过的流行病。部分原因在于强调进展。将那些没有出问题的事情视为理所当然是人类天性的一部分。是的，公共卫生总体上没有得到认可，因为当我们成功时，什么都不会发生。而当我们失败时，就会成为头条新闻。当然，随之而来的也有确实发生的流行病。
And of course, COVID was kind of that thunderclap, that moment of cataclysm. And one response from the federal government during the pandemic was to put a moratorium or a pause on evictions around the country when many people couldn't work. and this was to prevent homelessness in ways that might spread the virus even further. Now, that moratorium first began in a kind of regular way with Congress approving of the moratorium. But when Congress failed to renew it, it was actually the CDC that used its own authority to issue the moratorium in 2021 because federal law gives the CDC the authority to enforce regulations that are necessary to prevent the spread of communicable diseases.
当然，新冠肺炎就像是那声惊雷，是一场灾难性的时刻。大流行期间联邦政府的一项应对措施是在全国许多人无法工作时对驱逐令实行延期或暂停，
So the moratorium was ultimately challenged in court, and the Supreme Court put a halt to it the same year that it was issued. Now, this was after your time as director, but we were wondering, when you head an agency like the CDC, when you have to make a really big decision like this, do you think primarily and only about the public health decisions? Or are you also thinking, well, I have kind of a legal framework in my mind, too, to make sure that this, if it is to be challenged, we can have some safe assumptions about it going forward. So I'm not a lawyer. I'm a doctor. I will say that I found some of the regulatory approaches used during COVID, during both the Trump and Biden administrations of CDC not to be appropriate. And I think they were kind of inevitable because Congress didn't act.
这是为了以可能进一步传播病毒的方式防止无家可归。现在，这种延期最初是以一种常规方式开始的，得到了国会对延期的批准。但当国会未能延长它时，实际上是疾控中心利用自身的权力在 2021 年发布了这项延期，因为联邦法律赋予了疾控中心强制执行防止传染病传播所必需的法规的权力。所以这项延期最终在法庭上受到挑战，最高法院在其实施的同一年叫停了它。现在，这是在你担任主任之后的事了，但我们想知道，当你领导像疾控中心这样的机构时，当你必须做出像这样非常重大的决定时，你的首要考虑且唯一的考虑是公共卫生决定吗？还是你也在想，嗯，我的心中也有一种法律框架，以确保如果这受到挑战，我们可以对未来的发展有一些安全的假设？所以，我不是律师。我是一名医生。我要说的是，我发现在新冠大流行期间、在特朗普和拜登政府时期疾控中心所采用的一些监管方法并不恰当。我认为它们在某种程度上是不可避免的，因为国会没有采取行动。
I see. So because there was a failure to act on the part of Congress, CDC authorities were used in ways they had never been used before on both eviction moratorium and on some immigration issues that probably haven't stood up to legal review. But your question is a broader one. And I think always public health should consider as broad a set of risk.
我明白了。因此，由于国会未能采取行动，疾控中心（CDC）的权力被以从未有过的方式用于颁布驱逐令暂停令，以及一些可能经不起法律审查的移民问题。但你的问题更广泛。我认为公共卫生部门历来都应该将各种尽可能广泛的风险。
and benefits as possible. There's a misconception, I think, that CDC didn't consider, oh, what harm will it be to the economy or to education if there are closures. I wasn't there at the time, but I can tell you that in all of our recommendations, there is explicitly an understanding of the non-direct health-related costs,
和效益纳入考量。我认为有一种误解，即疾控中心没有考虑到，哦，如果实行封锁，会对经济或教育造成什么损害。我当时不在那里，但我可以告诉你，在我们所有的建议中，都明确包含了对非直接健康相关成本的理解，
whether that's of vaccinations or or other recommendations, and it should be. Now, CDC isn't always privy to what all of those things might be. So to give you an example, during the Ebola epidemic, we wanted to track all incoming travelers, but they were coming into dozens of airports 24-7, and we had no way to do that. I didn't know as CDC director that the transportation,
无论是疫苗接种还是其他建议，本来就该如此。然而，疾控中心并不总是能了解到所有这些可能的情况。举个例子，在埃博拉疫情期间，我们希望追踪所有入境旅客，但他们通过几十个机场24小时不间断地入境，我们对此束手无策。作为疾控中心主任，我并不知道交通部门，
that the Transportation Department had the authority to mandate that all flights funnel into a limited number of airports. So instead of 32 airports, they could make it just five. And with just five, we could figure out a way to track every incoming passenger from the affected countries. So when you have a cross-government collaboration, you often identify new ways to do something more effective. or costs or benefits or potentials that you didn't know otherwise. So there's been this ongoing debate about whether the president should have the freedom to fire heads of agencies within the executive branch for any reason. The CDC director can be fired for any reason. And in fact, Susan Menares was fired by the Trump administration this past August after only one month on the job.
交通部门有权强制将所有航班汇聚到少数几个机场。因此，他们可以将32个机场缩减至仅仅5个。只要通过这5个机场，我们就能想出办法追踪来自受影响国家的每一位入境旅客。因此，当你开展跨政府合作时，你往往能找到新的方法来做得更有效率，或者发现你原本不知道的成本、效益或潜力。因此，一直以来都有这样一场争论：总统是否应该出于任何原因随意解雇行政部门下属机构的负责人。疾控中心主任可以因任何原因被解雇。事实上，苏珊·梅纳雷斯在今年8月上任仅一个月后，就被特朗普政府解雇了。
Do you think that's a good idea for the president to have that kind of latitude? And is there a better model for this? The fact is, and this came up when just recently Congress made the CDC director position one that is Senate confirmed. There are pros and cons of that approach. But fundamentally, if you're a CDC director and the administration doesn't agree with you, you're not going to be able to get your job done. So it doesn't really make sense to keep someone in if they're not part of the team. That's different from a technical agency that may need to make non-political decisions on the economy or something else. But there's a related issue which has to do with what are called national statistical products.
你认为总统拥有这种自由裁量权是个好主意吗？有没有更好的模式来处理这个问题？事实上，正如不久前国会将疾控中心主任职位改为需经参议院确认时所讨论的那样，这种方法各有利弊。但从根本上讲，如果你是疾控中心主任，而政府不同意你的看法，你就无法完成工作。因此，如果一个人不再是团队的一员，把他留在岗位上就没有意义了。这与那些可能需要就经济或其他方面做出非政治性决策的技术机构不同。但还有一个相关的问题，那就是所谓的国家统计产品。
It sounds like a boring term, and it is a boring term. But it's actually quite – Please explain. It's quite an important term. There are certain publications or series that are considered so important that they be not politically tampered with, that they have been national statistical products, including some of the publications from the National Center for Health Statistics, which is part of the CDC. It actually was independent for a while, then it became part of the CDC. And as the CDC director, I was allowed to know what they were going to publish in terms of the title. Like they're going to publish, not even the title, they're going to publish a publication on X.
听起来像是个枯燥的术语，也确实是个枯燥的术语。但它实际上相当——请解释一下。这是一个相当重要的术语。某些出版物或系列被认为至关重要，绝不能遭到政治篡改，因此它们成为了国家统计产品，其中包括国家卫生统计中心的一些出版物，该中心隶属于疾控中心。它实际上曾独立过一段时间，后来又并入了疾控中心。作为疾控中心主任，我有权知道他们在标题方面将要发布什么内容。比如他们将要发布，甚至不是标题，他们只是要发布一份关于X主题的出版物。
But I was not permitted legally to see that report before the media saw that report. Interesting. And that also goes for things like the Bureau of Labor Statistics employment data, because you really want people to have confidence in it. Now, in recent months, I learned, really to my astonishment, that that was not a legal or legislative protection. That was the result of a directive from OMB. And if it can be established by OMB, it can be changed by OMB. So I think it is really important for everyone that there is information that is produced by the experts in that. information with transparent methodology and hasn't been meddled with by a politician.
但在法律上，我不被允许在媒体看到该报告之前先行查阅该报告。有趣的是。劳工统计局的就业数据等也遵循这一原则，因为你确实希望人们对这些数据充满信心。然而，在最近几个月，我惊恐地了解到，这并非一项法律或立法保护。这只是管理和预算办公室（OMB）的一项指令的结果。既然可以通过管理和预算办公室确立，它也可以被管理和预算办公室更改。因此我认为，对于所有人来说，至关重要的一点是，相关信息必须由该领域的专家来产出，这些信息应具备透明的方法论，且没有受到政客的干涉。
I think that's so important. And one of the things that people may not realize is when an agency like the CDC is producing this kind of very important health data, it's not just for public consumption at large. There's a whole network of researchers outside of the federal government that absolutely depend on this data, can't create or collect it on their own. it's just too expensive to do. And so there's this vast infrastructure that really the CDC and other similar public health agencies are kind of upholding up as, you know, from the bottom. Absolutely.
我认为这太重要了。人们可能没有意识到的一点是，当像疾控中心这样的机构产出这种非常重要的健康数据时，它不仅供广大公众消费。联邦政府之外还有一整套研究人员网络，他们绝对依赖这些数据，因为他们无法自行创建或收集，成本实在太高了。因此，存在着这样庞大的基础设施，疾控中心和其他类似的公共卫生机构实际上是在从底层支撑着它。绝对是这样。
And this goes also for some of the survey systems. There are surveys that CDC does and the results are anonymized so you could never find who answered what. But researchers, they're goldmines of information. And CDC will do the basic. analysis of them and make them available for researchers to look at more. And that's another essential function of CDC getting back to your first question of, why do we need a CDC.
这也适用于某些调查系统。疾控中心会开展一些调查，其结果会被匿名化，因此你永远无法查明是谁回答了什么问题。但对研究人员来说，这些都是信息的金矿。疾控中心会对其进行基础分析，并提供给研究人员作进一步查阅。回到你的第一个问题，为什么我们需要一个疾控中心，这是它的另一个核心功能。
It establishes the standard for that and then states figure out how to apply that. So if you had a magic wand, what would be at the top of your list for reforming the CDC? Well, CDC is undergoing attacks political and even physical. that are unprecedented. Right. We've had for the first time the firing of a CDC director. About a quarter of CDC staff
它确立了相关标准，然后各州再弄清楚如何去落实。那么，如果你有一根魔法棒，你改革疾控中心的首要愿望是什么？嗯，疾控中心目前正遭受着史无前例的政治甚至人身攻击。没错。我们第一次经历了疾控中心主任被解雇的情况。大约四分之一的疾控中心员工
have either fired or resigned. Most of the leadership of the agency has left. You have, by last count, a dozen or 15 political appointees basically running the agency that has never happened before. You mentioned the advisory committee on immunization practices,
被解雇或辞职了。该机构的大多数领导层都已离职。据最后统计，有十几到十五位政治任命官员实际上在运营该机构，这在以前从未发生过。你刚才提到了免疫实践咨询委员会，
that's a committee that has used the highest standards of evidence and protection from conflicts of interest for decades. And it's been basically taken over by a group of people who have very limited knowledge of vaccines, most of them, not all of them, and who have made recommendations that are so at variance with basic medical concepts that the professional societies, doctors, nurses, and the insurers have said, we're going to ignore what it says because it doesn't make sense. So this is a very difficult time, and I don't think we're going to go back to the past. I think we're going to have to go forward to a CDC that's faster, that's better at communicating, that has better partnerships and alliances, and that delivers results that people can feel,
这是一个几十年来一直采用最高标准证据和利益冲突防范机制的委员会。而它基本上被这样一群人接管了：他们绝大多数（并非全部）对疫苗知之甚少，并且他们提出的建议与基本医学概念严重背离，以至于专业协会、医生、护士和保险公司都表示：“我们要忽视它的说法，因为它毫无道理。”因此，这是一个非常艰难的时期，我认为我们无法回到过去了。我认为我们必须向前迈进，建立一个反应更快、沟通更擅长、拥有更好伙伴关系和联盟、能够提供让人切身感受到的成果的疾控中心，
that provides tangible benefits for people to understand and live a healthier, safer life. I think one of the things that has to happen more is that CDC needs to be more tightly aligned with state and local governments because I had the benefit of joining CDC as director after having been New York City Health Commissioner. So I had a pretty good sense of what was needed on the front lines, and I felt there was a little too much of a disconnect between folks at the CDC headquarters in Atlanta and folks out there on the front lines. And this is not a political comment about this policy or that it's how fast you need results, how practical recommendations are. And one of the things I did while I was there was I increased the number of CDC staff embedded in state and local health departments, especially early in their career. So people could come in, spend a few years at a city or county or state health department, learn what it looks like on the front lines, and then rotate to CDC where they would be able to provide more practical, helpful guidance. The person who founded CDC, Joseph Mountain, wrote that he thought every CDC officer should have spent at least a year as a county health officer.
它为人们理解并过上更健康、更安全的生活带来切实的利益。我认为需要更多发生的事情之一是，疾控中心需要与州和地方政府更加紧密地结合在一起，因为我有幸在担任纽约市卫生局局长之后加入疾控中心担任主任。所以我对前线需要什么有相当不错的直觉，我感到亚特兰大疾控中心总部的人员与前线的人员之间存在着一点点脱节。这不是对某项政策的政治评论，而是关于你需要多快获得结果、建议有多实用。我在任期间所做的事情之一，就是增加了派驻到州和地方卫生部门的疾控中心员工数量，尤其是他们职业生涯早期的员工。这样人们就可以进来，在城市、县或州的卫生部门度过几年，了解前线是什么样子的，然后轮调到疾控中心，从而能够提供更实用、更有帮助的指导。疾控中心创始人约瑟夫·芒廷曾写道，他认为每位疾控中心官员都应该在县卫生局至少工作一年。
Long enough, he wrote, to have proposed a budget and gotten it through. with the city council. Well, this brings up an interesting point that I'm interested in your personal biography. I mean, the mayor of a city, the mayor of the city in New York, you know, has very different powers than the president of the United States. There's also a big difference between, you know, what states and cities can legislate versus what the federal government can do. Still, you know, in terms of public health, you know, well, basically, what were you able to do as NYC health commissioner that you could never propose as the CDC director, I guess is the question I'm asking? Well, I'll tell you, I found it a shock when I got to CDC because the CDC director is way, way, way less powerful than the New York City Health Commissioner. Oh, no.
他写道，时间足够长，才能提出一份预算并通过市议会的审批。嗯，这就引出了一个有趣的点，我对此很感兴趣，关于你的个人履历。我的意思是，一个城市的市长，纽约市的市长，你知道的，其拥有的权力与美国总统有很大不同。各州和各市所能立法的范围与联邦政府能做的事情之间也存在巨大差异。不过，就公共卫生而言，嗯，基本上，作为纽约市卫生局局长，你能够做哪些作为疾控中心主任永远无法提出的事情呢？我想这正是我要问的问题。好吧，我来告诉你，当我来到疾控中心时，我感到非常震惊，因为疾控中心主任的权力比纽约市卫生局局长要小得多、多、得多。哦，不会吧。
So as New York City Health Commissioner, I had substantial flexible resources that I could devote to emerging health threats or potential new programs. And the way that worked was if money weren't spent in one area, we could spend it in another area. And inevitably, money gets underspent, and so you can spend it. That's not how the federal government has traditionally worked. If you don't spend the money in the way that Congress allocates it, we were always told you could go to jail because Congress is your board of directors. And so that was called an Anti-Deficiency Act violation. But with this new theory on impoundment, that's a problem. That seems not to be the way the current administration is working.
因此，作为纽约市卫生局局长，我拥有大量灵活的资源，可以将其投入到新出现的健康威胁或潜在的新项目中。其运作方式是，如果一个领域的资金没有花完，我们可以把它花在另一个领域。不可避免地，资金会有所剩余，所以你可以花掉它。传统上联邦政府的运作方式可不是这样的。如果你没有按照国会分配的方式花钱，我们总是被告知你可能会坐牢，因为国会就是你的董事会。因此这被称为违反《反亏空法》。但是随着这种关于扣押资金的新理论的出现，这就成了一个问题。这似乎并不是现任政府的运作方式。
But that meant that I literally, literally had 20 times more flexible dollars as New York City Health Commissioner that I had as CDC director. Second big difference was that as the CDC director, I had very little control over the different parts of CDC because there are something like 200 budget lines and they all run their own programs, divisions and centers. And the director is kind of, you know, at best conducting an orchestra, but more realistically kind of walking alongside. So when I wanted to start a new program of putting hundreds of staff into state and local health departments, I had no way to do that. I had to go kind of cup in hand to my center and division directors that would you support three or four? Would you support five or six? The other thing that was so very different was actually authority. So as New York City health commissioner, I had a lot of authority.
但这意味着，作为纽约市卫生局局长，我手中实际拥有的灵活资金字面意义上是我担任疾控中心主任时的20倍。第二个巨大区别是，作为疾控中心主任，我对疾控中心的不同部门几乎没有控制权，因为这里大约有200个预算项目，它们各自运营着自己的项目、处室和中心。而主任充其量也就是在指挥一个交响乐团，但更现实的情况是，有点像在旁边陪走。所以，当我想启动一个将数百名员工派驻到州和地方卫生部门的新项目时，我根本没有办法做到这一点。我不得不带着哀求的姿态去找我的中心和处室负责人，问你们能不能支持三四个？你们能不能支持五六个？另一件大不相同的事实际上是权力。因此，作为纽约市卫生局局长，我拥有很大的权力。
Like when I was assistant commissioner and I ran the tuberculosis control program, we modernized the detention laws. So if you had tuberculosis and you didn't take your medicines, we could order you detained in a hospital until you were cured. And, you know, if a restaurant is serving food and in unsanitary conditions, we could close it. If there's an environmental hazard in a place, we could order it to be abated.
比如当我担任助理局长并负责结核病控制项目时，我们使拘留法律现代化了。因此，如果你患有结核病却不吃药，我们可以下令将你拘留在医院里直到痊愈。而且，你知道的，如果一家餐馆在不卫生的条件下供应食物，我们可以勒令其关闭。如果某个地方存在环境危害，我们可以下令予以消除。
So there was a huge amount more of authority and power as a city health commissioner, especially New York City, because the city is kind of a hybrid between a state and a city. The New York State has delegated to New York City a lot of things that most cities don't have the authority to do. It has its own health code.
因此，作为城市卫生局局长，尤其是纽约市的局长，你所拥有的权限和权力要大得多，因为这座城市介于州和市之间，有点像一个混合体。纽约州已将许多大多数城市没有权限做的事情下放给了纽约市。它拥有自己的健康法典。
It has its own Board of Health. So I can say that coming from New York City, particularly with Mike Bloomberg, who has a public health school named after him and if it was willing to do public health stuff to the CDC, it was a very frustrating transition because the amount of authority and power was so much less, even though the organization is larger. Yeah, yeah. I mean, would you like to see that power sort of if there was a U.S. health? Commissioner, would that be a better system? I don't think that will ever happen. And we do have a very decentralized, a federal system in the U.S., where we decentralized the states.
它拥有自己的卫生委员会。所以我可以说，从纽约市走出来，特别是与迈克尔·布隆伯格共事——他有一所以他名字命名的公共卫生学院，并且愿意对疾控中心采取公共卫生措施——这是一次非常令人沮丧的转变，因为权限和权力小了那么多，尽管这个机构的规模更庞大。对，对。我是说，你是否希望看到这种权力——如果在全美设立一个卫生局局长，那会不会是一个更好的系统？我认为这永远不会发生高度集权。我们在美国拥有一个非常分散的、联邦制的系统，我们将权力下放给各州。
What I think would be more effective is a system where there's more alignment between city, county, state, and federal. So that, not that everyone's working in lockstep, but if we're going to try to address the opiate overdose problem or reduce food poisoning or reduce strokes or hard attacks or cancers, we can say, all right, let's do this in a coordinated way that's learned from each other. Maybe we'll try three different approaches and compare them. Right now, there's just too much distance between the different parts of the public health system.
我认为更有效的系统是城市、县、州和联邦之间能够更好地协调配合。这样，并不是说每个人都整齐划一地行动，而是如果我们打算解决阿片类药物过量问题、减少食物中毒、或者减少中风、心脏病发作或癌症，我们可以说：“好吧，让我们以一种相互借鉴的协调方式来做这件事。”也许我们会尝试三种不同的方法并进行比较。目前，公共卫生系统各个部分之间的距离太远了。
Yeah. Well, what's so interesting about your tenure in New York City is that, you know, what you did there really shows that public health is a thing that, you know, sometimes is wildly unpopular at first and then becomes normalized. But it's exactly the kind of thing that people don't vote. for. Nobody votes for, I want to end smoking in restaurants and bars. But then we decide, oh, this is much better. I can breathe. So that's, I think, the real challenge for public health in a democracy. I tell in the book two stories from the Bloomberg administration. When
是的。嗯，你在纽约市任职期间最有趣的地方在于，你在那里所做的事情确实表明，公共卫生有时在一开始会极其不受欢迎，但随后会变得正常化。但这恰恰是人们不会为之投票的那种事情。没有人会投票说：“我想禁止在餐馆和酒吧吸烟。”但随后我们决定：“哦，这好多了。我能呼吸了。”所以，我认为这是民主制度下公共卫生面临的真正挑战。我在书中讲述了布隆伯格政府时期的两个故事。当时
Mayor Bloomberg was running for re-election for the first time, I was really enthusiastic about his leadership because he was an excellent manager. He was really focused on public health. We had made a lot of progress. We had banned smoking in bars. We had raised. tobacco tax, we've done new things on HIV care and prevention. And so I asked one of his inner circle, how can I help with his re-election? And she said, I'll tell you how you can help. Let us put you in a closet and put duct tape over your mouth until after the election. And after he won re-election, he called all of the commissioners together.
布隆伯格市长首次竞选连任时，我对他的领导力充满热情，因为他是一位出色的管理者。他真正专注于公共卫生。我们取得了很大进展。我们在酒吧禁烟了。我们提高了。烟草税，我们在艾滋病护理和预防方面做了新工作。因此我问他核心圈子的一位成员，我该如何为他的连任出力？她说：“我来告诉你怎么出力。让我们把你关在一个壁橱里，用强力胶带封住你的嘴，直到选举结束。”在他赢得连任后，他把所有的局长都召集到一起。
And he said, you know, look, I financed my own election. don't owe anything to anyone. And our job is to do the hard stuff that nobody else is going to do, like building the new water tunnel for New York City, a multi-billion dollar effort that would take many, many years, and he would never get the credit for. And so it's, it's, Mayor Bloomberg said, it's kind of a mark that we're not doing our job that my approval rating is, you know, in the mid-70s. And if we do our job, the approval rating will come down. And, uh, The head of his communications unit shouted from the back of the room, we're counting on you, Tom.
他说：“大家看，我自己出资竞选。我不欠任何人任何东西。我们的工作就是去做别人都不愿做的难事，比如为纽约市修建新的输水隧道，这是一个历时多年、耗资数十亿美元的工程，而他永远不会因此获得荣誉。”所以，布隆伯格市长说，我的支持率如果在70%左右徘徊，这本身就是我们工作没做到位的标志。如果我们真正做好了工作，支持率就会下降。而且，他的宣传部门负责人从房间后排大喊：“我们指望你了，汤姆。”
So, yes, it can be unpopular. But I will say when we made all restaurants and bars smoke-free, it was a huge fight, a huge fight. And, you know, the tabloids had a field day criticizing the mayor and me and everybody else. and by first or second year after, people really appreciated it. And the opposite, people are going to not go to bars and restaurants, the opposite happened.
所以，是的，这可能会不受欢迎。但我得说，当我们让所有餐馆和酒吧都无烟化时，那是一场巨大的斗争，一场硬仗。而且，你知道的，小报天天拿市长、我和其他所有人开涮，大肆批评。但在实行后的第一年或第二年，人们真正开始赞赏它了。结果与预期相反，人们并没有不去酒吧和餐馆，相反的情况发生了。
Oh, there's so much more pleasant. We'll go there, we'll eat, we'll hang out for longer. And I think this is the case with many public health problems. Another example of this, and it's important to see the kind of evolution of social change I discuss in the book is, think of a generation or two, when it was normal for a family to load up the car, drive to a beach, not wearing seatbelts, put on not sunblock, but tanning lotion, have a few beers, hop back into their car without putting on seatbelts, drive to a restaurant, smoke in the restaurant, have a few more drinks, and then not wearing seatbelts again, drive home. I think you might have been spying on my family.
哦，这里愉快多了。我们会去那里，会吃饭，会待更长时间。我认为许多公共卫生问题都是如此。另一个例子，而且看到我在书中讨论的社会变迁的演变非常重要，想象一下一两代人之前，当一个家庭把车装满，开车去海滩，不系安全带，不涂防晒霜而是涂助晒剂，喝几罐啤酒，不系安全带就跳回车里，开车去餐馆，在餐馆里抽烟，再喝几杯，然后再次不系安全带开车回家。我想你可能在暗中监视我的家庭。
Well, most families, because that was the social norm. That was the social norm. Right. And there's still too much driving under the influence. There's still too much skin cancer. There's still too much exposure to secondhand smoke. But those things are much less common and they're no longer the social norm. And that's the reflection of huge progress, progress that has saved millions of lives.
嗯，大多数家庭都是这样，因为那是当时的社会规范。那时的社会规范就是这样。没错。现在仍然有太多的酒后驾车。仍然有太多的皮肤癌。仍然有太多的二手烟暴露。但这些情况已经少见多了，它们不再是社会规范。这折射出巨大的进步，拯救了数百万生命的进步。
It's also a social norm to not die of measles. and not being an iron lung. And that has happened for enough decades that people probably, you know, like they're playing footsy with risk that they probably don't understand. How do you make them understand that? I think this has been a real challenge.
不因麻疹而死，也不使用铁肺，这也是一种社会规范。这种情况已经持续了足够多的十年，以至于人们可能，你知道的，就像在玩弄他们可能并不理解的风险。你如何让他们理解这一点？我认为这一直是一个真正的挑战。
First off, there have been anti-vaccination movements ever since the first vaccines. And in the book, I talk about Ben Franklin, whose four-year-old child died from smallpox, and there was misinformation that he had died from the vaccine. And Franklin got on the social. media of his day, which was his gazette that he was putting out, to say, no, the child died from the virus itself. And even a half a century later, when he wrote his autobiography, he very
首先，自从出现第一批疫苗以来，就一直存在反疫苗运动。我在书中谈到了本杰明·弗兰克林，他的四岁孩子死于天窗（应为天花，此处按上下文意译），当时有谣言说他是死于疫苗。于是弗兰克林登上了他那个时代的社交媒体，也就是他创办的公报，声明说：“不，孩子是死于病毒本身。”甚至在半个世纪后，当他写自传时，他非常
movingly went back to that episode and he said, you know, basically put yourself in the position of a parent whose child has died. Wouldn't you have rather done everything possible to prevent it? So there are effective ways to find the messaging. We also find that vaccines are. victims of their own success. We don't have any problems getting people in Africa to get vaccinated against meningitis because it's a terrible disease and they see people with terrible meningitis. So, yeah, I want that vaccine. This means that we need to improve communication.
动情地回到了那个插曲，他说：“你知道的，基本上把自己放在一个失去孩子的父母的角度来想。难道你宁愿没有尽一切可能去阻止它吗？”因此，找到正确的传达信息的方式是行之有效的。我们还发现，疫苗是自身成功的受害者。我们在非洲推广脑膜炎疫苗时没有任何问题，因为这是一种可怕的疾病，而且他们亲眼见过患有可怕脑膜炎的人。所以，是的，我想要那种疫苗。这意味着我们需要改善沟通。
We need to listen carefully to people's concerns. We need to provide objective data. Fortunately, although some of the myths and the falsehoods get a lot of coverage, still, the vast majority of Americans understand that vaccines are life-saving and get their kids vaccinated on schedule. But that's not an assured progress. We're seeing this firehose of falsehoods about vaccines, and it means that our defenses against microbial killers are going to get weaker. Dr. Tom Frieden, thank you so much for taking the time to talk with us, and I really enjoyed talking with you. I enjoyed your book. Thank you. It's been a pleasure speaking with you both.
我们需要仔细聆听人们的关切。我们需要提供客观的数据。幸运的是，尽管一些神话和虚假信息得到了大量报道，但绝大多数美国人仍然明白疫苗能够拯救生命，并按计划给他们的孩子接种疫苗。但这并不是稳操胜券的进步。我们看到关于疫苗的虚假信息如消防水龙带般喷涌而出，这意味着我们对微生物杀手的防线将变得更加薄弱。汤姆·弗里德曼博士，非常感谢您抽出时间与我们交谈，我真的很享受与您的交流。我很喜欢您的书。谢谢。非常高兴能与你们两位交谈。
Thank you so much. Joining us next month, we'll be moving on to Article 3, the Judicial Branch. The 99% Invisible Breakdown of the Constitution is produced by Isabel Angel, edited by committee, music by Swan Real, mixed by Martine Gonzalez. 99% Invisible's executive producer is Kathy 2. Our senior editor is Delaine Hall. Kurt Colstead is the digital director. The rest of the team includes Chris Barube, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Lay, Lashemaddon, Jacob Medina Gleason, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, Talon and Rain Stradley, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. The art for this series was created by Aaron Nestor. We are part of the series XM
非常感谢。下个月加入我们时，我们将继续探讨第三条，即司法分支机构。《99%无形》宪法解析由伊莎贝尔·安吉尔制作，委员会编辑，音乐由斯旺·雷尔创作，马丁·冈萨雷斯混音。《99%无形》的执行制作人是凯茜·2（Kathy 2）。我们的高级编辑是德莱恩·霍尔。库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁贝、杰森·德莱昂、埃met特·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、维维安·莱、拉谢·马登、雅各布·梅迪纳·格利森、凯利·普莱姆、乔·罗森伯格、塔隆和雷恩·斯特雷德利，以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。《99%无形》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。本系列的美术作品由亚伦·内斯特创作。我们是天狼星XM
podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful, Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us on all the usual social media sites as well as your own Discord server where we have fun discussions about constitutional law, about architecture, movies, and music, all kinds of good stuff. It's where I'm hanging out most these days. You can find the link to the Discord server
播客家族的一员，现在总部设在北边六个街区的潘多拉大楼。位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的上城。你可以在所有常见的社交媒体网站上找到我们，也可以在您自己的Discord服务器上找到我们，在那里我们进行关于宪法、建筑、电影和音乐等各种好玩内容的有趣讨论。这些天我大部分时间都在那里闲逛。你可以在Discord服务器的链接中找到
as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及《99PI》的每一集往期节目，网址是99PI.org。谢谢。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。